[Musik]
hallo zusammen wir machen heute einen
Subway Cookie Plätzchenteller meine
Subway Macadamia white schok Cookies kam
mir richtig gut bei euch an ist aber
auch schon eine Weile her und heute gibt
es den Subway Cookie Teig also dieses
richtig schön tschuike dieses softe aber
es gibt drei Varianten die Subway so
noch nicht verkauft und die ich einfach
selber Feier und lecker finde und ich
starte jetzt direkt mit dem Rezept ihr
findet die ganz genauen Mengenangaben in
meinen Videos ja immer unten in der
Infobox dadurch ist das Video nicht so
lang atmet und es geht einfach direkt
los so ich habe jetzt ein Zimmer warme
Butter wie gesagt und jetzt brauchen wir
braunen Zucker und den gebe ich jetzt
hier mit dazu Vanille extra könnt ihr
auch schon mit dazu geben und dann mixe
ich das jetzt zwei Minuten lang auf
höchster Geschwindigkeit ihr könnt doch
euer Handrührgerät benutzen aber ich
nehme heute die Küchenmaschine so und
dann geht's weiter
[Musik]
ich vergaß kurz wie viel Power meine
Maschine hat also macht nicht die
höchste Geschwindigkeit sondern die
mittlere die reicht da vollkommen aus
und jetzt gebe ich Eier mit dazu am
besten haben die jetzt Zimmertemperatur
also im besten Fall wenn nicht ist es
auch nicht so dramatisch aber es wäre
halt besser für die ganze Masse dass sie
sich einfach besser verbindet so wenn
ihr es kommt immer darauf an welche Eier
Größe ihr habt oder ihr verwendet ich
habe jetzt Eier der Größe M zwei Stück
ihr könntet auch ein Ei der Größe L
nehmen dann werden zwei Eier der Größe L
zu viel dann nimmt ein eine Größe L und
fügt ein bisschen Milch mit dazu aber
schreibe ich euch alles in die Infobox
müsst euch alles nicht merken das riecht
jetzt auch noch ganz kurz ein und danach
sieht ihr auch schon mehl mit Backpulver
mit zu Masse
[Musik]
so beim Mehl denkt ihr euch
wahrscheinlich oha was für eine riesen
Mehlmasse das wird der staubtrocken aber
dann rührt ihr und nach ein paar
Sekunden werdet ihr merken dass es so
eine richtig schöne klebrige Keksmasse
ist genauso muss die sein das ist die
perfekte Basis und ich habe noch einen
Tipp für euch habe es heute extra nicht
gemacht weil ich weiß es handelt sich
alle zu Hause aber ihr könnt auch
Weinstein verwenden nicht verwechseln
mit Weinstein Backpulver was es halt im
Supermarkt gibt das gibt es eher nicht
im Supermarkt das ist ein amerikanisches
Ding jetzt haben wir im Shop und da
könnt ihr zum Beispiel ihr habt ja jetzt
hier drei Teelöffel Backpulver hallo
drei Teelöffel Backpulver sind hier im
Rezept und ihr könntet auch zwei
Teelöffel Backpulver und einen halben
Teelöffel Weinstein nehmen denn Weinchen
hat noch mal so eine chemische Funktion
im Backprozess verhindert dass der
zuckerkristallisiert und macht es
einfach noch mal so ein bisschen truiger
also mein Tipp probiert es gerne aus
aber euch zuliebe habe ich gedacht heute
mache ich jetzt einfach mal nicht für
die die es halt noch nicht zu Hause
haben so und jetzt will ich drei
Varianten machen und teile mir meinen
Teig deshalb auf also immer ein Drittel
in jede Schüssel und dann zeige ich euch
was für Varianten es sein werden
so die erste Variante ist so richtig
winterlich wir machen eine Variante mit
Marzipan und ich finde es irgendwie so
schade ich wäre jetzt lange nicht mehr
bei Subway aber ich finde es cool wenn
die auch so saisonweise mal Limited
Editions hätten ich weiß nicht ist das
vielleicht sogar so und ich beste jetzt
hier voll umsonst und eigentlich machen
dir das ich war so lange nicht mehr da
obwohl ich ein Subway direkt hier um die
Ecke habe aber ich mache jetzt hier
Marzipan rein das ist Marzipanrohmasse
einfach in so kleine Stückchen schneiden
und dann hebe ich die so ein bisschen
unter den Teig und da habe ich mir
gedacht passt jetzt auch noch Haselnuss
Krokant ganz gut dazu und ich gebe da
noch ein paar Schokodrops mit rein da
könnt ihr Vollmilch oder Zartbitter
nehmen weil ich finde so ein kleiner
schokoanteil musst du auch mit drin sein
und dann ist die erste Variante schon
fertig
[Musik]
jetzt nehme ich mir meinen Teig
Portionierer bzw Eisportionierer und
gebe jetzt die die
Welt das Wort nicht die Cookie Masse
genau die kommt jetzt hier aufs Blech
mit Abstand denn sonst habt ihr ein
riesen Cookie sonst verlaufen die so
ineinander und anschließend könnt ihr
euch auch so ein bisschen die Hände
befeuchten und ganz leicht platt
andrücken aber nur ganz leicht
[Musik]
so Variante Nummer zwei ist salted
Caramel ich liebe es heute Caramel in
allen Varianten ob als Cheesecake als
Kekse als Getränk so und liegt die
Karamellbonbons waren schon glaube ich
ein bisschen länger beim Schrank aber es
ist kein Problem denn wenn ihr eh
gebacken und die Teile ich jetzt das
sind diese diese sahne-bonbons die Teile
ich jetzt einfach so ein bisschen in
große Stücke boah die sind die sind ja
richtig hart ah okay aha aha okay der
ich weiß nicht der war glaube ich
der war echt ein bisschen zu hart nehmen
wir den aber wie gesagt die werden eh
gebacken daher dürft ihr euch jetzt
nicht vorstellen dass die so hart
bleiben die zerlaufen dann so ein
bisschen und dann rühre ich ja
eigentlich das wieder in meinen Basis
Teig und dann gebe ich noch ein bisschen
Salz mit dazu das ist jetzt grobes Salz
das werde ich vielleicht noch ein
bisschen feiner schneiden und dann rühre
ich das einfach ein und dann kommt auch
auf Backblech
[Musik]
so variante 3 ist jetzt Macadamia ja das
gibt es schon aber es gibt kein
Macadamia in Kombination mit dunkler
Schokolade und ich würde jetzt gerne
Macadamia mit Double choc machen also
quasi einmal die macadamianüsse grob
hacken und dann so Schokodrops
hinzufügen einmal Vollmilch einmal
Zartbitter weil ich finde auch die in
Kombination mit dunkler Schokolade sehr
sehr lecker ja und dann man ist unsere
drei Varianten freue ich mich jetzt
schon aufs Backen ich habe den Ofen
übrigens schon vorgeheizt ihr könnt euch
bei diesem Rezept aussuchen ob ihr das
mit Ober und Unterhitze einzeln backt
oder parallel mit Umluft aber dazu kann
ich euch gleich noch mal was erklären
[Musik]
so und entweder backt jetzt wie gesagt
jedes Blech einzeln bei 180 Grad Ober
und Unterhitze im vorgeheizten Backofen
der sollte wirklich immer vorgeheizt
sein und dann brauchen Sie 9 bis 12
Minuten ist eine ungewöhnliche Backzeit
weil das diese drei Minuten Spanne da
dabei sind aber sich daran dass jeder
Ofen anders backt daher schaut bitte
nach 9 Minuten rein nach zehn nach 11
und 12 sie dürfen dann am äußeren Rand
ganz leicht hellbraun sein und oben
sollten Sie noch hell bleiben ihr habt
das Gefühl der Ball also die bräuchte
noch ein paar Minuten um dieses Cross
goldbraune zu haben aber das ist dann zu
trocken daher immer frühzeitig
rausnehmen und sie backen auch auf dem
heißen Blecher und ein bisschen nach das
müsst ihr auch Bedenken ich muss heute
allerdings so dass ich alle drei auf
einmal Backe und schalte dann 20 Grad
kälter also 160 Grad dafür aber Umluft
der zirkuliert die Luft und alles ist
heißer daher müsst ihr immer diese 20
Grad abziehen und dann auch wieder 9 bis
12 Minuten backen
[Musik]
so frisch aus dem Ofen bei mir haben sie
tatsächlich 12 Minuten gebraucht sondern
gibt es noch diesen Trick mit dem mogeln
dass sie schön rund sind das geht aber
nur so lange sie ganz ganz heiß und
frisch aus dem Ofen kommt nehmt euch
einfach einen großen Ausstich oder könnt
euch auch irgendwie eine Schüssel oder
sowas nehmen und dann geht er einfach zu
den Cookies und dann schwenkt ihr so ein
bisschen hin und her dann werden sie
wieder kugelrund und ich meine das Auge
muss ja auch mitessen ne das sieht ja
dann auf jeden Fall einfach schöner aus
[Musik]
dann habe ich hier Macadamia doubleshop
auf Englisch
habe ich dann marzipan mit Schoko und
kokant
neue Produkt rausgebracht
schon eine Speichel im Mund so
zusammenfließt und man richtig Bock
drauf
geil sagen gerade wirklich auf insta so
das wiegt so Kind aber das kommt von
Herzen das ist einfach so wenn wenn
etwas schmeckt dann ist es so die erste
Reaktion geil richtig richtig geil
haut man so ein paar mal drauf aber
richtig gut also im positiven Sinne
das probieren wir alles parallel gleich
ach mir so ein Stück Marzipan entgegen
gekommen ich weiß dieser passt richtig
gut
das mal so bei Subway als Limited
Edition im Winter wie wär's mal mach
doch mal sowas
ich lachen muss im letzten Video diese
ja das muss man im kW anbieten oder in
jedem Video der aber ist doch so weißt
du wieso guck mal alle sind immer
eifersüchtig auf mich weil dieser kann
ich gut kochen und so ein bisschen voll
verwöhnt und so ich würde gerne mit den
Teilen danke
deswegen also deswegen bin ich kein
romantischer Mensch von Kiki weil das
bringt nichts hier ist noch nicht
romantisch bin dann lacht sie können wir
machen den zusammen auf oh der ist
richtig warm
Leute
also man merkt halt wirklich wenn sie
aus also wenn man die aus dem Ofen holt
merkt man einfach dass sie total weiß
und ihr könnt sie nicht mal anheben
daher auf jeden Fall 10-15 Minuten
auskühlen lassen dann werden sie immer
fester
ich muss sagen ich finde alle sehr sehr
geil mein Favorit ist tatsächlich
solltet Caramel dann Macadamia und dann
Marzipan aber alle sehr sehr lecker alle
sehr sehr lecker
so bevor ich euch jetzt gehen lasse
kannst du das gleich mal rüberreichen
Ofen also ich wollte sagen das hier zum
Beispiel es sieht jetzt augenscheinlich
so aus als wäre der ganz normal gar
gebacken na da ist halt goldbraun aber
der ist zu trocken der war jetzt
ungefähr 15 Minuten drin das waren drei
Minuten zu lang ich habe es vergessen
aber cool denn so kann ich Euch zeigen
wie halt der Unterschied ist ne kann ich
mal anrufen
er ist trocken ist jetzt gerade noch
warm und wenn der harte die dann noch
trockener daher unbedingt darauf achten
dass wenn ihr wirklich die Kekse am Rand
sieht dass die goldbraun werden dann
sind sie fertig und nicht zu dunkel
werden lassen
naja wenn sie trotzdem essen in Kaffee
tunken oder so ich finde es nicht
dramatisch aber wenn es halt so ein Hose
Level gibt warum soll man das dann nicht
so haben
genau
so gut langen Test gehabt ich wünsche
euch jetzt viel Spaß beim Nachmachen und
sage bis zum
[Musik]
nächsten Mal